Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am really excited to show this to you as
I was looking to make this episode for quite
a while.
You'll see lots of beautiful slow-motion footage
during the narration.
And at first, it may seem disconnected from
the narrative, but by the end of video, you'll
understand why they look the way they do.
Now, before we proceed, let's talk about the
difference between interpolation and extrapolation.
Interpolation means that we have measurement
points for a given quantity, and we'd like
to know what happened between these points.
For instance, we have two samples of a person's
location at four and at five o'clock, and
we'd like to know where the guy was at four
thirty.
However, if we're doing extrapolation, we're
interested in guessing a quantity beyond the
reach of our sample points.
For instance, extrapolation would be predicting
what happens after the very last frame of
the video.
In our earlier episode, we talked about financial
extrapolation, make sure to have a look, it
was super fun.
The link is in the video description.
Optical flow is really useful because it can
do this kind of interpolation and extrapolation
for images.
So let's do one of them right now.
You'll see which it will be in a second.
So this is a classical scenario that we often
encounter when producing a new Two Minute
Papers episode - here, we have a 25 or 30
frames per second video on a 60 frames per
second timeline.
This means that roughly only every other frame
is duplicated, and offers no new information.
You can see this as I step through these individual
frames.
The more astute Fellow Scholars immediately
would point out that wait, we have a lot of
before and after image pairs, so we could
do a lot better!
Why don't we try to estimate what happened
between these images?
And that is exactly what we call frame interpolation.
Interpolation because it is something between
two known measurement points.
And if we run the optical flow algorithm that
can accomplish this, we can fill in these
doubled frames with new ones that actually
carry new information.
So the ratio here was roughly two to one.
Roughly every other frame provides new information.
Super cool!
So, what are the limits of this technique?
What if we artificially slow the video down,
so that it's much longer, so not only every
other, but most of the frames are just duplicates?
This results in a boring and choppy animation.
Can we fill those in too?
Note that the basic optical flow equations
are written for tiny changes in position,
so we shouldn't expect it to be able to extrapolate
or interpolate any quantity over a longer
period of time.
But of course, it always depends on the type
of motion we have at hand, so let's give it
a try!
As you can see, with optical flow, the algorithm
has an understanding of the motions that take
place in the footage, and because of that,
we can get some smooth, buttery, slow motion
footage that is absolutely mesmerizing.
Almost like shooting with a slow motion camera.
And note that the majority of these frames
were not containing any information, and this
motion was synthesized from these distant
sample points that are miles and miles away
from each other.
However, it is also important to point out
that optical flow is not a silver bullet and
it should be used with moderation and special
care as it can also introduce nasty artifacts
like the one that you see here.
This is due to an abrupt, high frequency change
that is more difficult to predict than a slow
and steady translation or rotation motion.
To avoid these cases, we can use a much simpler
frame interpolation technique that we call
frame blending.
This is a more naive technique that doesn't
do any meaningful guesswork and computes the
average of the two results.
Why don't we give this one a try too?
Or even better, let's have a look at the difference
between the original choppy footage, and the
interpolated versions with frame blending
and optical flow.
If we do that, we see that frame blending
is unlikely to give us nasty artifacts, but
in return, the results are significantly more
limited compared to optical flow because it
doesn't have an understanding of the motion
taking place in the footage.
So, the question is, when to use which?
Well, until we get an algorithm that is able
to adaptively decide when to use what, it
still comes down to individual judgement and
sometimes quite a bit of trial and error.
I'd like to make it extremely sure that you
don't leave this video thinking that this
is the only application of optical flows.
It's just one of the coolest ones!
But this motion estimation technique also
has many other uses.
For instance, if we have an unmanned aerial
vehicle, it's really great if we can endow
it with an optical flow sensor, because then,
it will be able to know in which direction
it needs to rotate to avoid a tree, or whether
it is stable or not at a given point in time.
And, with your support on Patreon, we were
not only able to bump up the resolution of
future Two Minute Papers episodes to 4K, but
we're also running them at true 60 frames
per second, which means that every footage
can undergo either a frame blending or optical
flow step to make the animations smoother
and more enjoyable for you.
This takes a bit of human labor and is computationally
expensive, but our new Two Minute Papers rig
is now capable of handling this.
It is fantastic to see that you Fellow Scholars
are willing to support the series, and through
this, we can introduce highly desirable improvements
to the production pipeline.
This is why we thank you at the end of every
episode for your generous support.
You Fellow Scholars are the best YouTube audience
anywhere.
And who knows, maybe one day, we'll be at
a point where Two Minute Papers can be a full
time endeavor, and we'll be able to make even
more elaborate episodes.
As I am tremendously enjoying making these
videos, that would be absolutely amazing.
Have you found any of these disturbing optical
flow artifacts during this episode?
Have you spotted some of these in other videos
on YouTube?
Let us know in the comments section so we
can learn from each other.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!